[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كلنا يعلم ان السرطان مرض قاتل يتغلغل في
الجسد حتى يهلكه لكنه لا يعدي ولا يقتل
الا صاحبه لكن هل سمعتم يوما بسرطان
يتغلغل في جوف الارض ويمتد لخارجها ليقتل
الارض من جوفها ويهلك ما عليها وما حولها
ولان اسرائيل تفرض ضوابط ومعايير مشدده
جدا فيما يتعلق بمعالجه النفايات داخل
الخط الاخضر
اتجهت انظارها نحو الخاصره الاضعف في
المنطقه الا وهي الضفه الغربيه
تحديدا نحو المناطق التي تسمى حسب اتفاقيه
اوسلو مناطق والتي اصبحت بمثابه المكان
المجاني للتخلص من النفايات الصلبه
والسائله والالكترونيه والطبيه وغيرها
وجميعها خطير كيف لا ونقل البرميل الواحد
من تلك النفايات لصحراء النقب يكلف
اسرائيل نحو الف دولار
[موسيقى]
وهذه المركز زي ما انت شايف هذه بتجمع كل
الميه شو اسمه وبعدين فيها فيها عشب وتهدم
السور والغنمه بتنزل هناك على البركه
وبتاكل وتقع جوات المي وقع عده حلال يعني
في جواتها والله يستر من الناس يعني
انه سرطان الارض الذي يتفشى وينتشر في
وادي ابو هند البدوي المحاذي لمكب نفايات
العبدلي الواقع على اراضي بلده ابوديس
شرقي القدس حيث تسكن تجمعات بدويه بعد ان
منعت من التنقل عبر الاراضي الشاسعه بسبب
بناء المستوطنات الاسرائيليه في جميع
الاتجاهات
ولان اهل مكه ادرى بشعابها كان لابد لنا
من لقاء من هو ادرى بشعاب وادي ابو هندي
الشيخ محمد الحمادي ابو يوسف
[موسيقى]
الميه اللي بتصير منه الغازات اللي بتطلع
من هذا من هذا المكان المياه اللي بتنزل
البلاستيك النايلون اللي بطير
غنمنا اذان الريحه في الليل ما بنقدر ننام
منها في عنا اولاد مرضاء من هذا الاشي
دائما الاولاد مرشحين وعندهم ازمات وفي
ناس مرض وصابوا يعني مرض السرطان الله
يشافي الجميع لكن هذا المكب هو يعني
بالنسبه انك مكرهه مكرهه صحيه لجميع
المنطقه مش بس انه لكن احنا بنتاثر خلال
ساعات الليل اكثر اشي فيه لانه كل الهواء
بيرجع الريحه علينا الهواء بجيب البلاستيك
علينا السيل بجيب المي علينا كل الامور في
التالي هي بتصب عنا
[موسيقى]